die zukunft des lebens machen immer mehr
wird in unseren haushalten automatisiert
der aufwand dafür ist immer geringer wo
die automatisierung will macht und wo
nicht jetzt bei den zwischen herzlich
willkommen ja heute porsche ich mal
selbst und versuche herauszufinden wo
sie smartphone wirklich lohnt sondern
verhalten und elektronikhersteller eine
rosige zukunft unsere wohnungen und
häuser werden automatisiert und unser
leben durch viel einfacher okay es ist
ja schon vieles auf dem markt also warum
sich ausprobieren und ich habe mir tipps
geräte von elgato philips und weiten
bestellt und ausprobiert in einer
automatisierten wohnung gelebt fangen
wir mit dem hype der letzten jahre an
dem staubsauger roboter er verspricht
das leben wirklich zu vereinfachen nie
wieder staubsauger aber ganz so einfach
ist es natürlich nicht aber ich kann nur
sagen ohne einen staubsaugerroboter
möchte ich nicht mehr leben
auch wenn der staub behälter viel öfter
geleert werden muss stundenlanges
staubsaugen gehört für mich der
vergangenheit hat da muss ich noch immer
manche lücke von hand augen
aber er nimmt schon eine menge arbeit ab
allerdings ist ein trugschluss die
automatische reinigung der wohnung wenn
man nicht da ist pustekuchen
nicht nur kabel müssen sorgfältig aus
dem weg geräumt werden die bot
verkannten und verheddern sich immer
wieder
oder bleiben irgendwo stecken so smart
wie sie dann nicht und man sollte in der
nähe sein denn der bot laut ansonsten
wird die arbeit nur zum teil erledigt
smart home hat also seine grenzen und
nur manches macht wirklich sinn
dabei habe ich festgestellt dass auch
meine waschmaschine smart ist bei ihr
kann ich ja einstellen wann sie anfangen
sollen zu waschen und so kann dann die
wäsche fertig sein wenn ich abends nach
hause komme und sie liebt da nicht
stundenlang in der wäschetrommel und
befühlt abend aber warum soll ich
eigentlich die beleuchtung über smart
home steuern ganz einfach da für disco
und innenraum gewittern er kann darauf
verzichten aber im ernst mit der
beleuchtungssteuerung kann man eine
menge machen
so kann man zum beispiel die lichtfarbe
ändern und am tag zb die räume mit
tageslicht beleuchten dadurch angenehmer
um zu arbeiten oder auch überhaupt alles
zu machen und abends dann mit warmen
künftig jede einzelne lampe kann
besteuert werden ferien können
festgelegt werden soll dass nachts das
licht im bad nur gewinnt angeht und das
finde ich wirklich praktisch ja und man
hat ja noch die discos das beste ist
aber die heizung die in meiner wohnung
normalerweise zentral für das ganze haus
geregelt wird
oder ich muss halt selber haben's am
thermostat anlegen und ihn an oder
abdrehen mit den smarten thermostaten
habe ich endlich eine automatische
nachtabsenkung das heißt nach regeln die
thermostate die heizung automatisch auf
eine niedrigere temperatur
ich kann sie so einstellen dass die
heizung ausgeht wenn ich nicht zu hause
bin oder kombiniert mit einem fenster
wände geht die heilung aus wenn das
fenster geöffnet wird das finde ich
wirklich einen riesigen gewinn der
sparte energie schont damit die umwelt
und ist wirklich komfortabel und smart
sehr sehr cool
ich bin gespannt was noch so alles auf
den markt kommt das wirklich so einen
mehrwert auch brett eins habe ich dabei
wirklich festgestellt ist ist voll cool
alles mit dem smartphone zu sparen aber
wirklich brauchen tue ich nur selten so
ein schalter ist immer noch das
praktische am besten ist wenn alles
automatisch läuft für viele anwendungen
brauche ich das total smarte überhaupt
nicht es soll funktionieren wie zum
beispiel die heizung mit dem fenster
sender das finde ich wirklich einen
riesigen fortschritt oder auch das
gedämpfte licht nach dem bad
wenn man mal eben kurz auf toilette muss
und nicht geblendet werden will
kleinigkeiten die einem wirklich das
leben erleichtert wird und jetzt können
wir noch im abo aufs auge drücken ganz
mag und die glocke läuten gestand bleibt
dran